everybody plays video games fortunately
Salman Rushdie hasn't thrown in the
towel he still writes novels his latest
Lucca and the fire of life has a Harry
Potter like title and like Rowling
series is set in a world of magic but
mr. Rushdie puts a modern twist to her
classic archetype he incorporates
elements of videogames into his
narrative take that mr. P Lucca his hero
is batted around like a super mario
brother but beneath the joy or Joystiq
fun of this virtual reality they are
enduring values and lessons and could
encourage in the face of adversity this
is something mr. Rushdie is
well-acquainted with I won't revisit the
persecution he underwent many of you
know the details and anyway he is
currently completing a memoir about that
dark time but Christopher Hitchens got
it right I think when he began a chapter
of his memoir devoted to his long
friendship with mr. Rushdie with the
following quote from The Satanic Verses
opposed work is to name the an Aimable
two pointed frauds to take sides start
arguments shape the world and stop it
from going to sleep he will shortly
discover mr. Rushdie is incapable of
putting any one reader or listener to
sleep he's welcome to hush
I agree
God looks like there's more than 100 of
you um
I should just say since I was accused of
having a Harry Potter ish title that
Haroon in the sea of stories was
published before Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone so let's see who got it
from whom at if she did steal one thing
for me I could point this out the
plagiarisms of JK Rowling there's a
there's a thing in her room the seek of
sea of stories that the bad guys have
reversed eyes you know they see in the
darker they can't see in the light so
instead of having light bulbs they have
dark bulbs and you know they come in two
rooms they switch on the darkness like
we would switch on the light and lo and
behold in the last Harry Potter book
she's got a thing called add illuminator
which you turn switch and it switches on
the darkness so yeah I guess she fred by
book you have to take it as a compliment
I think um yeah I wrote this book for my
for my youngest son Milan who's now 13
he was 12 when I finished the book I
gave it to him for his 12th birthday
because he'd been ever since he read
heard of the sea of stories he'd been
pointing out the injustice of there
being one brother with a book and one
without it to which there are two
answers by the way the first answer is
kid life aid fair and I decided to
choose answer B we just don't write the
book and his advice to me before I
started writing it it's a good advice he
said dad don't write novels write series
and I guess that did work out quite well
for JK Rowling but but it's taken me 20
years to come up with volume 2 in the
series so I'm not doing that well really
but it reminded me of another piece of
advice I was given long ago when I was
very young starting out as a writer
around the time that Midnight's Children
was coming out I was at a Christmas
publishing party at my my publishers in
England Jonathan Cape who was they were
then an independent publishing house now
they they're part of Random House um
anyway the the publisher there was a
famous British publisher called Tom
Marshall and his dad Kurt Marshall
also been a great publisher in Germany
and then it had to flee like many German
Jews have had to flee the rise of Nazism
and ended up in England and his his son
took on the family business if you like
but Kurt masla in Germany had published
a lot of the most kind of highbrow
eminent egghead German writers but his
real love was children's books which he
also published and he came up to me at
this party
kind of like the Ancient Mariner so
grabbed me by the wrists there was a
ship you know cetera and and he said it
is very heavy German accent which he
never lost he said you must a children's
book right and at that point at that
point by my oldest art was only about a
year and a half old and I said to him
you know well maybe when my boy grows up
I'll think of something to write for him
and he said no no yet I will to you a
storyteller and that he told me the
story of one of his most eminent and
egghead writers a writer called Erik
Kestner who he had constantly pestered
in the same way you must a children's
book writes and eventually only in
German and eventually Erik Kastner so
annoyed with by this that he went away
for two weeks and wrote something and
came back with the manuscript and
dropped it on Kurt marshallers desk and
say you're there you are now you can
shut up and this this was a book called
a meal and the detectives and it became
one of the greatest you know classics of
not just German children literature but
world children's literature and as Kurt
Marshall are said to be very happily he
said you know it's the only book of his
that still in print so you must a
children's book right so I you know
that's good advice and so I've done I
mean these two books you know maybe
there'll be the only two books of mine
that will remain in print which would be
cool by the way that would be fine
because I've had enormous pleasure
writing them and and I thought I'd just
share a bit of it with you it's it's a
story about a boy well Luka is the
younger brother of Haroon of the earlier
book but much later 20 years later he's
the child of his parents old age and his
father is is weakening you know his lose
the fire of life his
of life is burning lor and there's a
point in the early in the novel where he
falls into what's called a sleep but
it's clearly obviously something more
like a coma and he's obviously slipping
away gradually and Luca knows that there
are there's only one thing he could do
and that's what this books about so I'm
going to begin at the beginning of the
book there's a little acrostic verse
five lines long the dedication verse in
which each line begins with one letter
of my son Milan's name and it goes like
this magic lands lie all around inside
outside underground looking-glass
world's still abound all their true
tales this truth reveal not but love
makes magic real and the reason I really
just because it contains two of the
themes of the book one is that it is a
kind of love story it's not a romantic
love story but it's a story about the
love between parents and children
between fathers and sons mothers and
sons and about how far both the parents
and the children will go in the name of
that love so that's I think the if you
like the emotional root of the story and
and the other thing the story's about is
it is about this question of magic
question of the world of imagination of
dream of fantasy and what is the
relationship of that world to the world
that we live in how does it inform it
how does it color it how does it in many
ways change it and inspire it you know
and that's that's again the the the the
question out of which the book the book
arises I want to just mention yashide
haroon's Dada is of course a famous
storyteller the people who like those
who've read Haroon will know the people
who like his stories call him the ocean
of notions and the people who don't like
his stories call in the shower of blah
and and he has been telling Luca all his
life about this other world this
alternate reality and and and and the
alternate reality of course has a
geography which is necessary it also has
a history a probably also has a biology
but that mean
before children's books and this is just
a bit about the geography of it the
torrent of words by the way thunders
down from the sea of stories into the
lake of wisdom whose waters are
illumined by the dawn of days and out of
which flows the river of time the lake
of wisdom as is well known stands in the
shadow of the mountain of knowledge at
whose summit burns the fire of life this
important information regarding the
layout and in fact the very existence of
the magical world was kept hidden for
thousands of years guarded by mysterious
cloaked spoiled sports who called
themselves the Allium or learn at once
however the secret was out now it had
been made available to the general
public by Rasheed Khalifa in many
celebrated tales so everyone in kahani
was fully aware that there was a world
of magic existing in parallel with our
own non magic one and from that reality
came white magic black magic dreams
nightmares stories lies dragons fairies
blue bearded genies mechanical
mind-reading birds buried treasure
music fiction hope fear the gift of
eternal life the angel of death the
angel of love interruptions jokes good
ideas rotten ideas happy endings in fact
almost everything of any interest at all
the Allium whose idea of knowledge was
that it belonged to them and was too
precious to be shared with anyone else
probably hated Rasheed Khalifa for
letting the cat out of the bag but it is
not yet time to speak as we will
eventually have to speak of cats
not so I'm gonna leave that hag you have
to read the book to find out what that
means well what happens is he decides
that that he needs to do this he needs
to go and find this thing that's a
thought at the height of the mountain of
knowledge the fire of life because
that's the thing that can that could
save his father but of course he's being
asked to do to do that involves doing
three impossible things first he's got
to somehow get into the magical world
which you're not supposed to be able to
and if he's in there he's got to steal
the fire of life which nobody ever has
and if he steals it he's got to bring it
back which is impossible and so of
course that's what he decides to do and
in fact he he has companions by the way
he has two they're more friends than
pets they're animals one is a dog called
bear and the other is a bear called dog
and so every time he says dog you know
the bear cubs every time he's bad dog
comes anyway they're circus animals they
escaped circus animals and they become
his friends had been when they get into
the magic world they could talk which
helps too and at this point he does
somehow managed to just um ball if you
just stumble half a step to the right
you could find yourself in this parallel
reality and he manages to do that and
finds there somebody very alarming which
is a somebody who looks exactly like his
father but is not his father and I just
read you about this this is the kind of
the villain of the piece this Rasheed
Khalifa looked exactly like the famous
shower of blah
he was wearing his Panama hat and his
Vermilion Bush shirt and when he walked
and talked it became obvious that his
voice was Rasheed's voice and the way he
moved was an exact copy of the original
- but this Rasheed Khalifa could be seen
through not clearly but murkily as if he
were half real and half a trick of the
light as the first whispers of dawn
murmured in the sky above the figures
transparency became even more obvious
luca's head began to spin had something
happened to his father was this
see-through father some sort of
some sort of are you some sort of ghost
he asked in a weak voice you are
certainly something peculiar and
surprising to say the very least
am I wearing a white sheet am i clanking
chains do I look ghoulish to you
demanded the Phantom dismissively a Mari
scary okay don't answer that
the truth is that there are no such
things as ghosts or specters and
therefore I am NOT one and may I point
out that right now I am just as
surprised as you
Bears hair that's the dog was standing
on head on end a dog was shaking his
head in a puzzled way as if he had just
begun to remember something why are you
so surprised
Luka asked trying to sound confident
you're not the one who could see through
me after all the see-through Rashid
Khalifa came closer and Luca had to
force himself not to run away I'm not
here for you he said so it is unusual
for you to have crossed over when you're
in perfect health and your dog and bear
to buy the buy the whole thing is
exceedingly irregular the frontier is
not supposed to be this easily ignored
what do you mean Luka demanded what
frontier who are you here for the moment
he asked the last question he knew the
answer and it drove the other questions
out of his mind
oh he said Oh
then he's my father not yet said the
see-through Rashid
but I'm the patient type go away Luca
said you're not wanted around here
mister what is your name anyway the
see-through Rashid smiled a friendly
smile that somehow was not entirely
friendly I he began to explain in a
kindly voice that somehow did not feel
completely kind I am your father's dead
don't say that word Luka shouted the
point I'm trying to make if I may be
allowed to continue the fans have
insisted is that everyone's dead don't
say it
Luka yell
is different the Fantom said no two are
alike each living being is an individual
unlike all others their lives have
unique and personal beginnings personal
and unique middles and consequently at
the end it follows that everyone has
their own unique and personal dare don't
scream Luka and I am your father's or I
will be soon enough and at that time you
will no longer be able to see through me
because then I will be the real thing
and he I'm sorry to say will no longer
be at all nobody is going to take my
father away Luka cried not even you mr.
whatever-your-name-is with your scary
tales nobody said the see-through Rashid
yes you can call me that that's who I am
nobody is going to take your father away
and I am the nobody in question I am
your you might say nobodaddy that's
nonsense that Luka no no the see-through
Rashid corrected him I'm afraid that
nonsense is not involved you will
discover that I am a no-nonsense kind of
guy
Luka sat down on the front step of the
house and put his head in his hands nobo
daddy he understood what the see-through
Rashid was telling him as his father
faded away the Phantom Rashid would grow
stronger and in the end there would be
only this nobodaddy and no father at all
but he was very sure of one thing he was
not ready to do without a father he
would never be ready for that the
certainty of this knowledge grew in him
and gave him strength there was only one
thing for it he told himself this this
nobodaddy had to be stopped and he had
to think of a way to stop him to be fair
said noble daddy and in a spirit of full
disclosure I should repeat that you have
already achieved something extraordinary
by crossing the line I mean so perhaps
perhaps you are capable of further
extraordinary things maybe you're even
capable of bringing about the thing you
are even now dreaming up maybe you will
succeed in bringing about my destruction
an adversary how enjoyable how
positively darling I'm so excited
Lucca looked up what do you mean exactly
crossing the line he asked here where
you are is not there where you were
explained nobodaddy hopefully this all
of this that you see is not that which
you saw before this Lane is not that
Lane this house is not that house and
this daddy as I have explained is not
that one if the whole of your world took
half a step to the right then it would
bump into this world if it took half a
step to the left well let's not go into
that right now don't you see how much
more brightly colored everything is here
than it is back home this you see I
shouldn't even tell you really this is
the world of magic
Nuka remembered his stumbled in the
doorway in his brief but intense feeling
of giddiness was that when he crossed
the line and had he stumbled to the
right or the left must have been the
right wasn't it so so this must be the
right hand path mustn't it but was that
the best path for him shouldn't he as a
left-handed person have stumbled to the
left he realised that he really had no
idea what he was talking about why was
he on any sort of path at all and not
just in the lane outside his house where
might such a path lead and should he
even think of going down it should he be
thinking about just getting away from
this alarming nobodaddy and finding his
way back to the safety of his bedroom
all this talk of magic was much too much
for him
of course Lucar knew all about the world
of magic he had grown up hearing about
it from his father every day and he had
believed in it he had even drawn maps
and painted pictures of it the torrent
of words flowing into the lake of wisdom
and the mountain knowledge the fire of
life all that stuff but he hadn't
believed in it in the way that he
believed in dining tables or streets or
stomach upsets it hadn't been real in
the way that love was real or
unhappiness or fear it was only real in
the way that stories were real while he
were reading them or heat mirages before
you got too close to them or dreams
while you were dreaming is this a dream
then he wondered and the see-through
Rashid who called himself nobodaddy
noted slowly in a forceful way that
would certainly explain the situation
he said agreeably but it might not be a
dream and the thing about the magic
world one of the things about it is that
it does function as was said in the
introduction by Ariel it does work a
little bit like a video game you have
you could collect lives their lives are
everywhere you jump on mushrooms and
lives fallout you brought behind bushes
in their lives there so you he collects
Luca is able to collect lots of lives
which he needs because there's all kinds
of dangers and also like much many
magical worlds it has a gatekeeper and
you can't get into the magic world until
you could get past the gatekeeper I
thought I just read you the bit about
his confrontation with this nasty old
man he's been collecting lives he's got
about 350 s he's got 315 remembered my
own book he had collected 315 lives
he's now developed a three-digit counter
up in the top corner of his eye which
tells him how many lives he's got when
the old man of the river came up onto
the Strand again with his terminator in
his hand
Luca looked around panicked leaf or
somewhere to hide and at the same time
tried desperately to remember what his
father had told him about the old man
who it seemed was not just one of rashid
Khalifa's inventions after all or else
he was here in the world of magic
because rashid Khalifa had made him open
Luca remembered the way his father had
told the tale the old man of the river
has a beard like a river it flows right
down to his feet he stands on the Strand
with a gun in his hand the nastiest old
man you could meet and here indeed was
that very old man with his long white
river beard at his enormous blaster
coming out onto the riverbank climbing
up onto the Strand Luca did his very
best to summon back the memory of what
else the Shah of blah had told him about
this malevolent river demon something
about asking the old man questions no no
riddles riddles that was it Rasheed
loved riddles and he had tormented Luke
harbored riddles day after day night
after night year after year
until Luca had become good enough to
torment him back Rasheed would set each
evening in his favorite squashy armchair
and Luca would jump onto his lap even
though Surya scolded him warning that
the chair wasn't strong enough to take
their combined weight Luca didn't care
he wanted to sit there and the chair had
never broken or not yet anyway and all
that riddling was about to come in handy
after all yes the old man of the river
was a Riddler
that's what Rashid had said about him he
was addicted to riddling the way
gamblers were addicted to gambling or
drunkards to drink and that was how to
beat him the problem was how to get
close enough to the old man to say
anything when he had that Terminator in
his hand and looked determined to shoot
on sight Luca dodged from side to side
but the old man kept coming right at him
and even though first bare the dog and
the dog the bear tried to get in the way
a couple of blasts blew them to pieces
that obliged them to wait until their
bodies regrouped and a moment later Luca
too had been blasted again and had to go
through the whole business of flying
apart into a million shiny fragments and
then joining up again making those
little sucking noises feeling relieved
that losing a life was not the same
thing as dying then it was back to wife
Catherine anyway the next time the old
man comes up no sooner had the old man's
head come into view that Luca yelled at
the top of his voice riddle me riddle me
read which he knew from his evenings
with Rashid was the time-honored way of
challenging a Riddler to a battle the
old man of the river stopped in his
tracks and then a big nasty smile spread
across his face who calls me he said in
a coin cackle of a voice who thinks he
can outplay the rates on meister there
were des enigma the behavior kappa d sha
the lord of the riddles do you know what
you risk
do you understand the wager the stakes
are high could not be higher look at you
you're nothing you're a child I don't
even know if I want to face you know I
won't face you you are not worthy oh
very well if you insist
and if you lose child then all your
lives are mine do you understand all
your lives are mine
the final termination here at the
beginning you will meet your end and
this is what Luca could have said in
reply but did not preferring to remain
silent and what you don't understand you
horrible old man is that in the first
place it's my father who is the riddle
king and he taught me everything he knew
what you further don't understand is
that our riddle battles went on for
hours and days and weeks and months and
years and therefore I have a supply of
tough brain twisters that will never run
out and what you don't understand most
of all is that I've worked out something
important namely that this world I'm in
this world of magic is not just any old
magical world but the one my father
created and because this is his magic
world and nobody else's I know secrets
about everything in it including a
terrible old man about you what he
actually said aloud was this and if you
lose old man then you will have to
terminate yourself not just temporarily
but once and for all how the old man
laughed
he'd go forward until he wept not only
from his eyes but through his nose as
well he held his sides and left from
side to side and his long white beard
cracked in the air like a whip
that's a good one he said finally
panting for breath
if I lose that's priceless let's begin
but Luca wasn't going to be fooled that
easily Riddler's are tricksters he knew
that much and you had to nail down the
deal before you began the battle or they
would try to wriggle out of it later on
if you lose you will do as I have said
he insisted the old man of the river
made a peevish face yes yes yes he
replied if I lose I will self terminate
auto terminate termination of me by me
will occur
hehehe blast myself to bits permanently
Luka said firmly once and for all
the old man grew serious at his face
coloured unpleasantly very well he
barked yes permanent termination if I
lose in a word perma nation but as you
are about to discover child I am not the
one who is about to lose all his lives
bear dog were in a state of high
agitation but now Luka and the old man
were circling each other staring each
other down and it was the old man who
spoke first in a hard greedy voice
pushing roughly through teeth that
seemed hungry to eat up little luca's
life what goes around and around the
wood but never goes into it
the bark of the tree said look at
once--and shot back it stands on one leg
with its heart in its head cabbage
snapped the old man what is it you could
keep with after giving it to someone
else your word I have a little house
that I live in it alone it has no doors
or windows and to go out I must break
through the wall egg what do you call a
fish without an eye you call it a fish
what do you see monsters eat fish and
ships why was 6 afraid of 7 because 7
ate 9
what has been there for millions of
years but it is never more than a month
old the moon when you don't know what it
is that it's something but when you know
what it is then it's nothing
that's easy Luca said badly out of
breath a riddle they had been circling
faster and faster and the riddles had
been coming at greater and greater speed
this was just the beginning Luca knew
soothe and soon the number riddles would
start then the story riddles the
difficult stuff still lay ahead he
wasn't sure if he could last the course
so the thing was not to let the old man
dictate the pace and manner of the
contest it was time to play the Joker in
the pack
he stopped circling and put on his
grimaced expression what he asked goes
on four legs in the morning two legs at
noon and three legs in the evening the
old man of the river stopped circling -
and for the first time there was a
weakness in his voice and a tremble in
his limbs what are you playing at he
demanded feebly that's the most famous
riddle in the world yes it is said Luca
but you're stalling for time
answer me four legs two legs three legs
said the old man of the river everyone
knows this one huh it's the oldest one
in the book
the she monster known as the Sphinx
Rasheed Khalifa used to tell Luca sat
outside the city of Thebes and
challenged all the travelers who passed
by to solve her riddle when they failed
she killed them then one day a hero came
by and knew the answer and what did the
Sphinx do then Luca asked his father she
destroyed herself Rashid replied and
what was the answer to the riddle Luca
asked but Rashid Khalifa had to admit
that no matter how many times he tried
to learn the blasted story he could
never remember the solution to the
riddle
so that old Sphinx he said not very
sadly she'd have eaten me up for sure
come on Luca said to the old man of the
river your time's up but the old man of
the river looked around in panic I could
just blast you anyway he said
Lucca shook his head you know you can't
do that he said not now not anymore
then Lucca allowed his expression to
become a little dreamy my father could
never remember the answer either he said
and this is my father's world of magic
and you are his riddle man so you can't
know what he couldn't recall and now you
and the Sphinx must share the same fate
termination the old man of the river
said softly yes
that is just and without more ado and
quite unsentimental II he lifted his
Terminator set the dial on maximum
pointed the weapon at himself and fired
the answer is a man Luca said to the
empty air as the tiny shining
smithereens of the old man of the river
blew away to nothingness who crawls on
all fours as a baby walks upright as a
grown-up
and uses a stick when he's old that's
the answer
a man everyone knows that so so he gets
on with it now how are we doing
questions or you want me to read another
little bit more eating okay yes there's
just one bit about what happens when
they get near nearer to the part of
magic they come across a very weird land
which is I'm very fond of which is the
land full of all the discarded
divinities of the human race you know
all the collects gods of Greece and Rome
and pure there you know they now have
nowhere to go except this kind of theme
park and he has to deal with them yeah
he's uh they're years he's oh by the way
he's on a flying carpet he's met this
this lady who's kind of the heroine of
the book called the Sultana of art which
is the art is a place where people
rather excessive and rude and stands for
over-the-top by the way and although
she's the Sultana she's so extremely
rude about people that she's really
known as the in Sultana
and she has a flying carpet very
usefully I've always wanted to have a
flying carpet in a novel and I finally
got one anyway so he's up on this flying
carpet and with all his friends and he's
got a you can see a long way he saw
below him the river of time flowing from
the distant invisible lake of wisdom at
the heart of the heart of magic which
was still too far away to be seen
outside the circular sea directly
beneath the flying carpet at that moment
were the vast territories of the badly
behaved gods the gods in whom nobody
believed anymore except his stories that
people once like to tell they don't have
any power in the real world anymore
Russia if I used to say sitting in his
favorite squashy armchair with Luka
curled up on his lap so there they all
are in the heart of magic the ancient
gods of the north the gods of Greece and
Rome the South American gods the gods of
Sumeria and Egypt long ago they spend
their time they infinite timeless time
pretending they are still divine playing
all their old games fighting their
ancient wars over and over again and
trying to forget that nobody really
cares about them these days or even
remembers their names that's pretty sad
Luka said to his father to be honest
with you the heart of magic sounds a lot
like an old folks home for washed-up
superheroes don't let them hear you say
that machine Khalifa replied because
they all look gorgeous and youthful and
luminous and well perfect being divine
or even X divine has its perks
and inside the magic world they still
have the use of their superpowers it's
in the real world that their
Thunderbolts and enchantments no longer
have any effect must be awful for them
Luka said to have been worshipped and
adored for so long and then just
discarded like last year's unfashionable
clothes particularly for the Aztec
deities from Mexico
Rashid said putting on his scariest
voice because they were used to
receiving human sacrifices the throats
of living people were cut and their
lifeblood flowed into the gods stone
goblets now there's no blood for those
disused gods to drink
you've heard of vampires most of them
are bloodthirsty long in the tooth
undead Aztec gods no wonder people
stopped worshipping them Luka begged or
it may be because they all behaved so
badly Rasheed said this Scott Lucas
attention the notion of gods behaving
badly was an odd one weren't gods
supposed to set an example to the people
whose gods they were not in the olden
days Rasheed said those olden and now
jobless gods usually behaved as badly as
people or actually much worse because
being gods they could behave badly on a
bigger scale they were selfish rude
meddlesome vain [ __ ] violent spiteful
lustful gluttonous greedy lazy dishonest
tricky and stupid and all of it
exaggerated to the maximum because they
had those superpowers when they were
greedy they could swallow a city when
they were angry they could drown the
world when they meddled in human lives
they broke hearts stole women and
started wars when they were lazy they
slept for a thousand years and when they
played their little tricks other people
suffered and died sometimes the God
would even kill another God by knowing
his weeks parted going for it
the way a wolf goes for the throat of
his prey maybe it's a good thing they
faded away Luka said but it must make
the heart of magic of peculiar sort of
place nowhere more peculiar in the
universe
Rashid replied and what about the gods
people still believe in Luka asked are
they in the heart of magic as well oh
dear me no said rashid Khalifa they are
all still right here with us
all right thank you well we we started
late but I've been given permission to
go on as long as you got questions so
bones microphone there I think that's it
if you want to otherwise we'll just
stand here or go home I could go home
but there's a lot of you somebody must
have a question yes all right it's very
good to see you again mr. Ashley oh you
a quick question what reflections of
fatherhood what lessons of being a
father did you incorporate really into
this bond being a father
well in general 12 13 year old boys are
deeply convinced that their fathers are
pretty useless and in in deep need of
being told how to do things have been
looked after so that deep psychological
truth is at the heart of this book in
which the boy has to save the father's
life but um but you know as I said it's
about love it's about it's about that
extraordinary bond between parents and
children now there's a lesson you know
except that that's a good thing you know
and worth paying attention to
Rasheed is quite a I don't know he's not
the most serious or solemn father he's
he's encouraging encourages his his
children in fanciful ways much to the
contempt of their mother who keeps
pointing out to them that the world is
real you know and as she says at one
point in the real world there are no
levels there are only difficulties you
know you have to learn how to deal with
those so so she she's quite scornful of
him to that his head is full of these of
airy-fairy notions you know but well she
married him didn't she so she stuck with
him now but they're a good they're a
good combination I think you know that
one of them is is is very very grounded
and interested in giving her children a
sense of the world as it is
and the other is very ungrounded and is
interested in giving his children the
sense of the world as it is not what
might be in perhaps should be and it's
good
Thanks Oh sir Rushdie uh uh I just
wanted to ask you a question about your
perspective on something because in
these stories and just closer yeah in
your stories in many of your works you
explore accident you explore a spiritual
side of human expression and of thinking
and combined with your support of more
humanistic organizations and education
and your personal experiences what place
do you think religious expression has
nowadays in society maybe the wrong
person to ask this question
I just have a sneaking feeling that you
might get a better answer from somebody
else
um look one of the one of the sort of
serious things behind the the joke about
the discarded guards is that all story
began a sacred narrative you know let's
say that the birth of story is his
religious story you know that was what
that was what we first did we found ways
of telling stories to explain the world
that we didn't understand and that
tended to be you know the great
questions that religion asked itself or
the question though the question of
origins how did we get here and the
question of ethics now that we're here
how shall we live and and and religions
told themselves stories to answer those
questions and that's what that was the
beginning of storytelling I think and of
course there's a point in which there
was a separation that stories became not
necessarily religious stories you know
there was kind of secularization if you
like but I mean I'm very conscious of
the fact that stories come from
religious narratives and that and that
those are rich you know of often rich
and full of interesting truths so that's
one part of my head another part of my
head thinks it's the worst thing in the
world you know it gets in the way and
screws us up more than almost anything
else we have string us up which is
plenty so as I say I'm the wrong person
because I actually have this problem
inside myself that on the one hand as a
maker of stories I understand where
stories come from on the other hand as a
person living in the world I don't like
the activities of popes at ayatollahs
and and and priests and I'd sooner do
without him
I mean I could be a lot ruder but I
think I'll stop there thank you good
evening I really enjoy reading the JA
word smile and ignorant journey on you
wrote this book over 20 years ago and I
was wondering if you have followed the
history of the country and if you have
thought about or have actually gone back
to Nicaraguan if so if you want to write
about it yeah no I mean thank you I it
was a kind of accidental book the Jaguar
smile oh and I went there in the mid-80s
during the Contra war and actually I
went when I was writing this novel
called The Satanic Verses and wasn't
going very well
oh it's kind of stuck and so I thought
well let me just put it to one side and
go and look at this people with real
problems you know and I had been
interested in the subject of Nicaragua I
had been involved in in England I had
been involved in the Nicaragua
solidarity campaign and so on and was
clearly an opponent of the Contra war
and and an opponent of the US
government's support of the Contra and
and so I was invited to go there and and
report on it
so I spent those at that time there and
and I was just very very moved by what I
saw you know and came back and couldn't
get it out of my head and so realize
that the only way I'd get it out of my
head was to write about it and so out
came this short reportage book written
at great speed one of the things I
thought is how ridiculous to be for the
United States be fighting a war against
Nicaragua where Nicaragua is so
incredibly in love with the United
States you know what they were obsessed
for example with major league baseball I
mean everyone in Nicaragua could tell
you every single person of Nicaraguan
origin who had ever played for a major
league baseball team you know and they
were obsessed with American poetry they
will read Ezra Pound for goodness sake
at Walt Whitman and Marianne Moore I
mean a lot more than probably most of
you do and I thought this is a country
which could so easily be made a friend
of America had ever wanted to be a
friend
America and instead because of the cold
those cold war days you know America's
backyard Soviet Union's area of
influence all that you know because they
were seen as being Marxists which some
of them were and some of them weren't
the Sandinistas they became they were
treated as an enemy you know and and I
just thought it was a tragedy this tiny
little country you know with a
population half the size of the island
of Manhattan was being treated as a kind
of real danger and menace thank goodness
it wasn't an age where people pretend me
to discover weapons of mass destruction
but but no I haven't been back I haven't
been back but I do have friends who I
made at that time were still friends I
mean the writers who Sergio Ramirez who
was vice president at that time still
now gone back to being a novelist his a
friend and joke on the belly was a great
poet you know it's still a very close
friend of mine and so yeah I stay in
touch and I think actually it's kind of
in worse shape now than it was then
unfortunately so yeah and the things
don't always have a happy ending but I
but I loved it I loved it as a place I'm
very very fond of it so happy to have
been there good evening mr. Rushdie like
you I have two sons and I read Haroon in
the sea of stories to each of them in
turn I wish that they were still young
enough that I could read this book to
them but I wondered what did your son's
how it was their reaction to the stories
that you wrote for them well I mean
fortunately they like them otherwise it
could be a little bit of a problem in
the family you know here you are kid he
has this book I wrote for you well it's
not that good dad it
and in fact when I was writing her in
the sea of stories there was a there was
a moment like that I'd written about
three or four chapters the first draft
of it I thought I'd better just try it
out on him to see how it's going you
know I gave it to my oldest son's offer
to read and when he read it I said well
what do you think and he said yeah yeah
I liked it dad and I said yes and he
said some people might be bored and I
said what do you mean what do you be
bored what's wrong with it
and he used this wonderful term he said
well it doesn't have enough jump in it
if I'll jump he said yeah I knew exactly
what he meant of course I said I could
do jump I said give me that back you
know and I would say right away it
rewrote it and gave it to him
the second draft at this time you know
through clenched teeth I said what are
you cigarettes out and he said no now
it's fine that's fine and it was
genuinely the best literary criticism I
ever received because it was
constructive I knew exactly what he
meant and I knew what to do about it
you know and that kind of honest
response was fantastically useful and in
this book again the passage I read about
about the kind of death figure you know
who calls himself nobodaddy I should
point out that the word nobo daddy is
not invented by me it's actually I think
first used by William Blake
in in in one of his poems and and Blake
uses it as an image of the devil
basically and it was also used by Joyce
and again it there it represents more a
devil figure than a kind of alternative
father you know but anyway so I'm only
perhaps the third person to use it but
it's Blake's word should give credit but
I'm worried about that because you know
it's kind of scary that idea I think and
and
and while children like to be scared
they maybe don't like to be really
disturbed by an image and and I worried
that that might be on the wrong side of
the fence you know and I gave it to him
to again I gave it to my son Milan to
read the first couple of chapters and I
gated told him nothing about it and just
said read that tell me what you think
and and he to my and I mean I was
crossing my fingers because I thought if
he doesn't like it I'm really screwed
you know because this is a really
important part of the plot that I've
dreamed up and fortunately he wasn't
freaked out by it and in fact without
prompting said that he thought it was
his favorite character and and then I
thought aha you know I thought this
kid's got a little darkness and and it
allowed me to mate so I thought I could
push that a bit further you know and in
my view is that it's a lot of it is
George Lucas's fault I think I think the
one thing that George Lucas showed us
all is that the bad guy is more
interesting than the good guy you know
there there there are no children out
there today pretending to be Luke
Skywalker there's not a single child
going I'm Luke Skywalker you know but
there's a lot of people wanting to put
on the helmet to do the weird breathing
you know and that idea that the bad guy
can actually be interesting and
sympathetic and that you know his story
can actually be the story you know
because of course the six Star Wars
movies are really the story of Darth
Vader you know and I think that there's
something about that that's interesting
to me you know that the children can
understand that even in evil there's
interest and you could go and you could
go in and see how interesting that is
and not be freaked out by it as long as
force as long as it's okay in the end
Thanks thank you very much for coming to
Miami and your your answer just now
began to segue into my question
you wrote a while back that The Wizard
of Oz movie was your very first literary
influence and I'm curious whether that
movie or whatever other movies
when you would still characterizes a
literary game well what happened what
happened with The Wizard of Oz I mean I
must have been 11 or 12 I saw it in in
Bombay in India when I was growing up
before I'd ever come to the West at all
and and I you know I liked it very much
and I went home and wrote a story called
over the rainbow my first short story
which was not about those characters it
was about a boy like myself in my
hometown walking down the sidewalk and
seeing not the end of the rainbow but
the beginning of the rainbow curving up
and away from him and rather usefully
the rainbow had steps cut into it you
know um so that he he way he goes on
this journey over the rainbow and he
meets all kinds of weird creatures which
I actually mercifully I forget and my
dad I wrote it all out if my dad took it
to the office it got his secretary to
type it up so it became my first
typescript you know and then he said
well you know if I leave it with you
you're gonna lose it so I'm gonna look
after it so he looked after it he lost
it I had you see what I mean about the
uselessness of fathers and so I don't
have it anymore but that was the first
story that's what I meant when I said I
thought it made a writer for the first
time I actually sat down and wrote a
story and and I think one of the things
about that story that is like the
classic quest narrative and therefore is
quite like this book is that the the the
process of the quest is not just you
know overcoming problems it also has to
do with personal growth that the Dorothy
who becomes the Dorothy who kills the
which is a very different Dorothy than
the Dorothy who is unable to protect her
little dog you know and and the what
happens Dorothy is she discovers that
all the grown-ups are useless you know
auntie em Uncle Henry are pathetic they
can't even protect her against the
horrible miss Gulch
you know the The Tin Man is rusty and
the Cowardly Lion is cowardly and the
Scarecrow is made
straw and The Wizard of Oz is a fake you
know pay no attention to that man behind
the curtain
you know he's there all all the
grown-ups are pathetic and so she has to
step into the grown-up position you know
she has to do what the grown-ups can't
do and that business of growing up as
part of the quest it's true if you go
right back to you go back to the holy
grail you know you don't find the holy
grail until you are worthy of finding
the holy grail you have to become the
person who is considered pure enough Sir
Galahad for the Grail to manifest itself
to you so in all these in all the
classic quest stories there's that idea
of becoming better you know through
through adversary through adversity
through the overcoming of difficulties
and the defeat of goblins or dragons and
so on becoming better and and I think
that's sort of what happens at this book
- I think Lucca grows up you know it's a
bits about a boy growing up and and
becoming more able to handle the world
you know by the end than he is at the
beginning thanks
you spoke of people being more
enthralled with Darth Vader what do you
make of Hitchens embrace of Bush and
Cheney you're asking me to talk about
Christopher's politics yes I didn't
agree with him but the thing about
Christopher is he is one of my dearest
friends and right now we're thinking
about something else regarding
Christopher you know and where he's
engaged in another battle and my
feelings are there I don't give a damn
what he thought about George Bush you
know thank you
George Bush is toast anyway are we done
all right I think we're done thank you
folks
thank you
mr. Rushdie will autograph books on the
other side of the elevators and Dave
Barry's party is upstairs on the fifth
floor Terrace and we'll see you back
here tomorrow morning for Carl Hiaasen
and Scott Turow